♪ ♪
- IT'S FRIDAY NIGHT.
MAKE SOME NOISE!
[crowd cheers]
- AW, YEAH!
- PUT YOUR MOTHER[bleep]
HANDS IN THE AIR.
- AW, YEAH!
PUT 'EM UP.
- IF YOU COOL LIKE A PIMP,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
IF YOU COOL LIKE A PIMP,
'CAUSE YOU'RE AN ACTUAL PIMP,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
IF YOU OWN A BUNCH OF WOMEN,
♪ ♪
IF YOU GONNA HIT IT ALL NIGHT,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
- YEAH, ALL RIGHT.
- IF YOU MAINTAIN AN ERECTION
FOR 12 HOURS, PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
- WHOO!
- WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF VIAGRA,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
♪ ♪
IF YOU A REAL-LIFE PLAYER,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
- WHAT? YEAH.
- IF YOU ABUSE WOMEN'S TRUST,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
- WHOA.
- IF YOU TREAT THEM
LIKE OBJECTS, PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
♪ ♪
IF YOU A REAL-LIFE GANGSTER,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
IF YOU KILL OTHER PEOPLE,
♪ ♪
IF YOU THE BIGGEST BOSS HERE,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
♪ ♪
IF YOU RUN AN ACTUAL DRUG RING,
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
[crowd groans]
IF YOU JUST REALIZED
THAT YOU'RE FULL OF [bleep],
PUT YOUR HANDS UP.
[crowd cheers]